willkommen bayern ein video wie es
wahrscheinlich schon seht so hier so
laptop und so es geht heute mal wieder
um
chatroulette die abschlussausstellung
lesen ich hab's ja letzte mal hier auf
die reihe bekommt irgendeine nummer zu
kriegen
das war mir auch peinlich okay geht das
video war trotzdem ganz cool glaube ich
und es hat mich aber wirklich sehr sehr
viele ausgelacht da hab ich mir hey das
kann sie auf dir sitzen lassen
ich versuch soll einfach noch mal und
wenn es nicht klappt könnt ihr mich
gerne in den kommentaren der ausleihen
dann nehme ich das hin ist okay als ich
will aber wenn sie euch gefällt daumen
nach oben beim letzten jahr waren es
10.000 likes und da schon drauf ist mega
fällt auf jeden fall 10.000 schafen
heute wieder unesco leb dein leben
youtuber vorbild bist du youtuber oder
soll ich sie sagen machst du youtube ich
auch ehrlich ja wirklich auf youtube
blockbuster warte ich kannst du hier
reinschreiben
ich glaube ich heiße black ops
ja ich mache eigentlich die chatroulette
so weil ich also ich hab das theoretisch
für wii gemacht das immer so weiter das
ist ein
ich versuche mal so normal zu erklären
aber bei der letzte folge nicht so
erfolgreich
ich bin mal anders sein ja ja genau
studiert hallo alles okay bei dir was
hast du da für ein schlimmes profilbild
bist du weißt du was du machst mir ein
bisschen angst grad
ja ich muss nach so allen leuten ja also
soll ich besser weg machen sonst
verfolgst du mich nachher noch erinnert
nur weil jemand nur bei denen die die
beleidigen die idee verfolgte dann ab
okay was auch du kannst zwischen euren
tipp geben ich versuche ganz jetzt schon
nummer zu klären aber glücklich frage
nach der firma snapshot über ins etwa
macht ah ok das könnte ich versuchen
doch hier
was ist ihr angeguckt hat das alles so
weist das ding ist ich wollte halt mit
seite folge davon bringt aber heute ohne
witz es geht nicht den glanz war dabei
aber so ich finde zwar ganz lustige
leute sowie dich aber sonst korrekt
angibt welche deshalb gleich wer noch in
jemand ihnen von ihm gehört main kanal
alles korrekt von hier was machst du für
videos eigenständigen ich glaube auf
einem tablett mal wieder als alter der
elfter ohne schalter credo wenn ihr das
gerade ihr könnt das ja ganz sehen wenn
ihr den deckel schauen auf jeden fall
noch ein politik vorbei und abonnierten
wenn ihr wollt dann hast jetzt ich weiß
nicht bei also erstmal bei instagram
hatte ich so ein erwähnt bei dem hat das
was gebracht also vergessen habe ich
auch nicht auf mittwoch fast geweint und
ich kann dir genau sagen wie alt war
kg oder so krasse ja der war das mal
ich versuche die ganze unser römern zu
klären aber klappt nicht so stell dir
vor ich würde jetzt fragen ob ich deine
nummer krieges als mädchen sagt man ja
dann wahrscheinlich nein de wie muss ich
fragen was man ja wird also
es kommt ganz darauf an wie du
auftrittst das heißt wie soll ich
auftreten
okay noch was muss ich meine haare
anders machen ist okay so vielleicht
noch sonnenbrille aufsetzen oder sogar
oder mit diese mütze so einfach okay
meinst du dann klappt es und dann
vielleicht ein bisschen länger
dem vibe reden das ist ein paar
sympathiepunkte sympathiepunkte sammeln
merkt sein führungsteam vorschlagen oder
alles klar
dann versuche ich das mal so mit diesen
tipps begebe ich mich jetzt mal auf die
weitere suche erst mit genauer
sympathiepunkte sammeln danach nummer
fragen
die leute sagen wollte als leider wieder
nicht geklappt aber was soll ich machen
wir könnten ja mal eure tipps in die
kommentare schreiben
dann gehe ich da vielleicht das nächste
mal darauf ein wenn es im nächsten teil
gibt werde ich dazu noch genug
selbstbewusstsein habe auf jeden fall
habe ich auch ein paar tipps willkommen
von irgendwelchen anderen leuten und ja
ansonsten steckt in anderen teil ab ist
hier verlinken auch noch mal in der
video beschreibung check das auf jeden
fall nie vergessen wir sehen uns am
nächsten sonntag wieder marco cup 2006
drin sind bestimmt und hat rein